is recovering at home after what she
describes
as a traumatic couple of weeks her
husband and brother-in-law have been
detained by police
and she says she suffered a miscarriage
while in government care
i had pain for three days so i was
admitted to the hospital on the 11th
i was given injections then my situation
got worse
there was a lot of bleeding and i had a
miscarriage
pinkie and her husband rasheed's ordeal
began when they went to register their
islamic marriage ceremony with the state
government
they were harassed outside court by a
group of hindu nationalists
because pinkie had converted from
hinduism to islam
the couple married in july before the
government in the state of uttar pradesh
passed an
order which makes it illegal for people
to change their religion
for the sake of marriage police are
detaining rasheed and his brother salim
while they investigate whether they
forced pinkie to convert
and pinky was taken to a government-run
woman's shelter
the hospital which treated her told al
jazeera they only gave her injections to
help with her pain
and light bleeding
we didn't give her any injection that
would lead to a miscarriage
we gave her the best treatment we could
according to her symptoms
and manage the situation conservatively
so it's wrong to say this
while it's unclear what caused pinkie's
miscarriage what is certain
is she was separated from her husband
because of the new law
the uttar pradesh government issued the
anti-conversion order last month
citing a campaign by muslim men to
forcibly convert hindu women
that's despite the fact no state or
central government department including
the national commission of women
has found any evidence of such cases
human rights lawyer rinda grover says
the bharatiya janta party or bjp
passes such laws to divide indians she's
preparing to challenge it
in court the bjp very openly
projects itself as a right-wing hindu
party
thus what we are noticing here is that
this is actually part of a political
agenda
an agenda both to polarize and terrorize
communities
pinkie says she's worried about her
future and also
rasheeds and saleems
i want my husband and brother-in-law to
come back i ask the government to
release them
i'm really worried i've lost my child
but please let my husband go
but with four other bjp rule states in
the process of passing similar orders
more couples are expected to be
criminalized for falling in love
and marrying people outside their
religion
elizabeth piranham muradhabad uttar
pradesh